E
FILM SESSION, YOU KNOW WHAT?
LET HIM SCORE.
>> BUT IT'S SO CRAZY TOHINK
ABOUT THINGS THAT ARE KIND OF
LIKEKE THE AI RULE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
LIKE THAT REALLY CAN BE ONE.
WE ALSO KNO DRESS CODE, LIKE
THOSE THINGS, LIKE, THE IMPACT
TH YOU HAD, THE THINGS THAT
CHANGED YOU BECAUSE OF YOUR
PRESENCE IS JUST -- I THINK
REALLY COOL AND JUST SPEAK SO
MUCH TO THE LEGACY.
YOU SEE HOW DOPE IT IS?
I MEAN, MAY HE REST IN PEACE,
WITH HIM CHANGING THE DRESS
CODE, IT WAS LIKE -- I MEAN, IT
WAS LIKE YOU TAKING THE IDENTITY
OF THESE PEOPLE AWAY.
NOBODY PLAYED THE SAMAME.
WE DON'T PLAY THE SAME.
WE DON'T LOOK THE SAME.
WHY SHOU WE DRESS THE SAME?
AND MY MENTALITY WAS ALWAYS --
WHEN I WAS COMING IN MY ROOKIE
YEAR, I WAS LIKE BICALLY NOW I
CAN BUY ALL THE CLOTHES THAT THE
GUYS AROUND MY WAY WANT BECAUSE
I CAN AFFORD IT NOW.
WHEN I WAS LEAVING THE ARENA, I
WAS GOING TO THE CLUB.
I WASN'T GOING TO CHURCH OR --
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
COMING UP WHERE I'M FROM, WHEN
YOU WORE A SUIT, YOU WERE
WEARING A SUIT TO THE CHURCH OR
A FUNERAL OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
AND MY WHOLEHING WAS WHEN
EVERYBODY SAW ME DRESSING THE
WAY I WAS DRESSING LIKE I WANTED
TO, LIKE -- AND EVERYBODY
STARTED DOING IT, THE NBA WAS
LIKE, HOLD ON, YOU KNOW WHAT I
MEAN?
AND IT GAVE US -- AND I KNOW
WHAT IT WAS.
IT WAS KIND OF A THUG LOOK.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
WHEN EVERYBODY WAS WEARING
SUITS.
WHEN I CAME UP, I NEVER WORE NO
SUIT TO THE PARK TO GO PLAY
BASKETBALL.
I WORE A SWEAT SUIT OR WHATEVER.
THE PERSON.CLOTHES DON'T MAKAKE
>> NO, NO, NO.
WHEN PEOPLE GO ROB A BANK AND
ALL THTHAT, WHAT DID THEY HAVE ?
SUITS.
OKAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
AND NOW IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
YOU MIGHT NOT LIKE WHAT THESE
GUYS ARE WEARING, BUT IT'S
BEAUTIFUL.
BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T EXPRESSING
THEMSELVLVES THE WAY THEY WANT .
>> IT'SS SO GOOD.
I LOVE THE FASHION.
>> I LIKE EVERYBODY ON THEIR
OWN -- THEY GOT THEIR OWN WAG
SWAG AND OWN PERSONALS.
I LOVE IT.
>> YOU LOOK BACK AND YOU THINK
WHY, HOW BAD THAT, HOW BAD WE
NEED TO CHANGE PEOPLE BECAUSE WE
FELT SO UNSURE ABOUT ONE PERSON.
>> PEOPLE A ALWAYS SCARED OF
IT.
BUT IF IT MAKES YOU
UNCOMFORTABLE IN ANY WAY, YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE A PROBLEM WITH IT,
ESPECIALLYHEN YOU'RE A HIGH
POWER.
I WANTED TO LOOK LIKE MICHAEL
JORDAN ON THE COURT.
I WANTED TO LOOK LIKE A
SUPERHERO.
LIKE I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY GUYS
RIGHT W WEAR DIFFERENT COLOR
SHOES IN THEIR UNIFO.
BUT THAT'S THEIR COLOR.
I ALWAYS LOOKED AT WHAT SUPERMAN
WORE RED, YELLOW ANDLUE.
BAT MON WORE YELLOW AND BLACK.
SPIDER-MAN WORE RED AND BLACK
AND BLUE.
>> BUT IT WAS WEIRD, TOO, WITH
THE WHOLE THUG THING, RIGHT?
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT, WE WERE
WEARING $1500 SES.
>> SUITS.
>> WHY DOES IT HAVE TO BE A THUG
WHEN I'M WEARING SOMETHING --
THEY NEVER SN A DO RAG IN A
HAT.
AND IT GOT SCARY.
BUT THEY WOULD AIR BRUSH MY
TATTOOS ON.
I REMEMBER THOSE THINGS
HAPPENING.
>> WHICH IS WILD.
>> LIKE THEY'RE TAKING PARTS OF
YOU --
>> YEAH.
WE WANT TO SUMMON YOU.
WE WANT YOUR GAME.
WE DON'T WANT THE CORN ROWS.
WE DON'T WANT THETATTOOS.
BUT EVERYTHING ELSE, WE COOL
WITH.
AND EVERYBODY WAS MAKING A BIG
DEAL ABOUT MY CORN ROWS.
LIKE I WAS JUST -- ARE WE --
>> YEAH.
>> I WAS TIRED OF PEOPLE PUCKING
MY HAIR UP ON THE ROAD.
I JUST BLOW MY HAIR OUT AND GET
CORN ROWS, THEN I DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THAT.
THAT WAS THE ONLY REASON I DID
IT.
IT DIFFERENT HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH ME TRYING TO LOOK LIKIKE A
THUG.
I WAS TID OF PEOPLE MESSING MY
HAIR UP.
>> ONE THING WE GREW OUT OF,
IT'S --
>> PARTY IS OVER.
>> MY TEAMMATES USED TO GET MAD
AS HELL AT ME.
I USED TO GO INTO BIG AND TALL
AND BOUGHT EVERYTHING UP.
>> WAIT, YOU WENT INTO BIG AND
TALL?
>> I DID.
I'M TALKING ABOUT BIG MEN ON THE
TEAM.
AFTER PRACTICE, I WOULD BEAT
THEM THERE AND I WOULDUY
EVERYTHING.
THEY WANT COME IN THERE AND GET
MAD AT ME BECAUSE I WOULD BUY UP
ALL THE BIG CLOTHES.
>> DID YOU JUST LIKE THE LOO
>> IT WAS IN STYLE.
AND PROBABLY I HAD THE LITTLE
MAN COMPLEX BECAUSE I ALWAYS
WANTED THE BIGGEST CAR.
I WAS 165 THEN.
SO I WANTED THE BIGGEST CLOTHES.
I DIDN'T WANT TO LOOK SMALL.
IT WAS JUST THE GUYS IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD USED TO LOOK LIKE